Beginning in the mid 1950s,
Dr. Homer Warner, one of the founders of Health Informatics,
began using computers for decision support in
cardiology at LDS hospital in Salt Lake City, now Intermountain Healthcare.
In the 1970s, Dr. Warner and his colleagues
created the Health Evolution through Logic Processing,
or HELP system, one of
the first electronic medical records systems and
perhaps the first designed to assist clinicians in decision making.
Intermountain replaced HELP II,
the successor to HELP,
with the Center system in 2015.
Dr. Warner died in 2012 and Intermountain named its research center after him.
The American Medical Informatics Association, or AMIA,
awards a cash prize in Dr. Warner's honor each year at its annual symposium.
You can see here that
the HELP system's knowledge based decision processor received data from
virtually all areas of the hospital to
provide a variety of clinical decision support tools.
Expert panels organized much of
the clinical knowledge and an early example of knowledge engineering.
In fact, in 1997,
Dr. Warner published the book,
Knowledge Engineering and Health Informatics.
Here in a diagram from that book,
you can see how clinical findings link to a diagnosis.
Note that this includes logical rules stating that if
findings A or B and any of the two other four findings are present,
the diagnosis is confirmed.
Here you see that HELP uses bayesian statistics to relate findings to diagnoses.
Note here in this system diagram we saw earlier,
that HELP included a longitudinal clinical data repository.
I doubt that many in the field today
realize that such a system was functional that long ago.